and our first
Speaker our first speaker is chrisy
Sharma and she'll be giving a talk well
she is a software developer in
artificial intelligence and has been for
around 5 years she'll be giving a talk
on innovation in the age of reg
regulation hi everyone can you hear me
okay um welcome to my talk on innovation
in the age of
Regulation um so we're going to be
talking about how to continue building
AI models as we have more R tape and
regulations in certain
industries um it's hard to believe that
it was just a year ago where we really
started seeing AI pop up in
mainstream I've been working in the AI
industry for four years now and I
remember that it felt kind of weird to
hear all of my friends starting to care
and talk about AI um it felt overnight
and it was kind of overnight in just
five days chat GPT went from not being
known to having a million users which is
the fastest compared to all of these
other applications that we are so used
to people started to get worried about
what AI means for our world and asked
ourselves does this mean that it's going
to take over how we think does this mean
it's going to change how we plan war and
where do we stop where is the line for
how to build Ai and where to use
AI is AI our friend or is it
well as this all started coming out more
and more countries started to put out
regulations around where AI can be used
how it can be built and most importantly
how that data can be accumulated without
the training data which is our data you
can't train an AI
model most notably is the eu's general
data protection act which was ruled out
a few years ago and coming up the
artificial intelligence
act and a little bit closer to home was
on Monday with Biden's executive order
outlining how we can use Ai and where is
the limit within the
US so as all this comes up it really
begs the question of how do we continue
innovating on regulated data how can we
make sure that we can build AI models
without impinging on the privacy of
personal and private
data and it's kind of a two-prong
question for AI Developers because you
want to continue building Ai and you
want to continue improving on the
technology that's out there but at the
same time you are also a consumer of AI
and so you understand um kind of the
notion of going too
far to really do that I'm going to talk
about why classical ml approaches don't
really work for training on data that
has protections around how you can copy
it or whether you can even access it at
all um for those of you who are more in
Industries like healthcare or
telecommunications you might know things
like the Hippa act where you can't
access or move the data off of the
original server that's it's
on so with classical machine learning
you typically have a server and then you
have the different devices that contain
the data the data is Red
Dot usually that data is copy or copied
over or we moved to the central server
which serves as both the data storage
and the compute for the
model the server does the computations
trains the model and outputs this you
know lovely thing that we end up using
and we end up kind of enjoying as a
consumer um depending on the
product the other approach to make um AI
more scalable well I'm sorry um there
are three issues with classical machine
learning the first one is is data
privacy which is what we're here about
today um it requires the data to be
moved from the devices to the central
server which means that you know in
certain countries you might have to
require consent meaning that you may not
get access to all of the data that may
be available and you may not be able to
do it at all in certain industries the
second one is security
concern so once that data is on that
Central server that you know some compan
owns it's their job to make sure that it
doesn't get leaked that there isn't some
kind of security breach because that can
cost millions of dollars as some
companies have seen in the past um and
then the third one is just scalability
um there's only so much you can
vertically scale just one server to
accommodate for training on as many data
sets as you can to ensure a
generalizable and diversified
model so that's why classical ml is it
necessarily going to be the best fit as
we continue moving into this more
regulated
environment but what about distributed
machine
learning so with distributed machine
learning you have the server and all of
the devices that contain your data that
you want to train on and just like
classical machine learning that data
moves to the
server and rather than the server just
handling all of the compute it'll
distribute the data across different
nodes in order to speed up computation
sometimes lowering cost and it'll train
a bunch of local models which will then
be aggregated into a final
model so this really solves the
scalability issue because we're now
leveraging horizontal scaling but we're
having the same issues with data privacy
and an increased issue with security
depending on how the architecture is set
up to distribute the data across the
different no
so in these cases we see that the data
has to move over to the compute or the
server but what if we could train our
model
using the compute where the data is
already located is there a way to do
that so in 2018 Google researchers asked
themselves this and they came up with
the approach of Federated learning which
is actually a type of distributed
machine learning that leverages all of
our devices to train the model rather
than you know Distributing data across
nodes in some server that we have no
knowledge
of with Federated learning you have a
server and you have the different
devices that contain the
data but rather than the data traveling
to the
server different um the compute on the
different devices train a local model on
the device itself and then sends model
weights which are then aggregated within
the central server to con uh create the
final Global model so the server never
touches the data it never copies it over
or moves it um it just contains model
waves and metrics which are typically
nonidentifiable and so in that way a lot
of different different um use cases
where you wouldn't be able to build an
AI model before you can now train a
model no matter how many devices you
have or what the laws are around the
data so this allows us to you know
protect data privacy which is really
helpful especially in Industries like
today where you can't do it at all um
and then it also helps with security
because you don't have to worry as much
around Security on server since it
doesn't contain anything that is um
liable for like personal data and then
it also addresses the scalability
concerns because now you are
Distributing the load but rather than on
your server you're Distributing it
across the different
devices
so just to reiterate the server contains
just the model weight and that is what
ends up creating the final model
mod so there's a lot of different
um things that are going on here to make
Federated learning possible there's the
networking and communication between the
server and the clients to make sure that
the model weights are being passed back
and forth properly and there's also just
a coordination of the aggregation of
those model weights to create the final
model so are there tools that make our
life a little easier um there are
actually quite a and we're going to
focus on three and then discuss one in
particular that I have used in the past
in order to train a federative learning
model the first one is PFT which was
developed by openm um pisi was at one
point one of the most popular among the
federative learning brainworks and it's
python um but it is undergoing a lot of
different changes and so there are
differences in the documentation um so
when
I was working on building Federated
learning model with my team um it ended
up being very confusing to follow
so that for that reason I haven't really
worked with PFT too much with Federated
learning um there's also tensor flow
Federated which is has a lot of
different features but it can be a very
steep learning curve for those of you
you who may be new to Federated learning
um my team found that it was kind of
difficult particular with the fact that
if you're not training your model using
tensor flow then um you can't really use
it it's not FR work agnostic or it's
mostly defi designed to work with tensor
flow and then the third one which is the
one that we're going to discuss today is
a small package called flower it was
created by a group of German researchers
and it is pretty friendly to use it has
a lot of features which are really
helpful for like beginner and
intermediate
but first things are like more complex
you may want to turn to some of the
other packages but for our purposes
today um we're going to see how flower
can help us build a beginner vetera
learning model and help us get started
um it's also framework agnostic which
means that if you're at the very
beginning of your project you can start
implementing the Federated learning
framework right away rather than having
to kind of wait until you blocked in on
the design for the model
I also support it because SpongeBob
supports it
um so flower Works um in the way that
you have a central server which is
called a flower client and then you have
different devices which are sorry you
have a central server which is called a
flower server and you have different
devices that are called flower
clients and it coordinates the
communication between the clients and
the flower server
so each of the clients will have their
own training data um but to initiate a
flower training round you need to First
give the server some set of weights to
kick off training cuz right now it has
nothing it's just waiting so it'll wait
for one client to connect to that server
and it'll kick off training so for
example on this mobile phone that's the
first client that this has connected to
it'll pick off training and wait until
it receives an initial set of
Weights the server will then pass down
that first set of weights to all of the
devices and kick off training across all
of those
devices there will be a local model for
each device based on the data that is
located on that
source and an evaluation round that will
happen using whatever data is on that
source as
well all of the devices once they're
finished training will set send up the
model weights to the server and all of
the weights are going to be different
because the data is different on each
device um the server will then aggregate
those weights and it'll average it using
whatever formula that you specified and
it will then send back down a new set of
Weights which is all going to be the
same to the different devices and kick
off another round of training so
basically every time the server sends
down weights it's the one set of Weights
that it's going to set send down to all
the devices and each device will then
run its own training round using its own
data and send back a unique set of
Weights which the server will then
Aggregate and kick off another R of
training
with so there's that back and forth
communication that ends up producing a
global
model the flower package in particular
has a lot of features but the three
features that I want to highlight are
how you can really improve your model
using the FED Federated learning
approach the first is metrics
aggregation so it allows you to define
the different ways that you can kind of
combine your performance metrics since
you're running a different evaluation
round on each of your devices you're
going to be suming up the weights and
the metrics to figure out the end of the
end model performance so you can decide
if you want to favorably wait other
clients or others or if you have a
specific formula that's unique to your
company or your team that you want to
use the second is model aggregation
techniques so this is about how you're
going to average the weights itself
before you send it back down to the
different devices um typically like when
you start with flower the default is
just something called Federated
averaging which is a simple average of
all the weights but if you wanted to do
weighted average or some custom
averaging you can do that as well and
the third one is model weight
compression so this will reduce the size
of the weights and allow for faster
communication and therefore faster
training between the server and the
clients so when IV is Federated learning
in the past um this you know the slowing
down that can happen um is really
improved when you figure out how to
implement that model we contion
feature
further improvements
are you can add more clients or data
sets so um you can figure out like okay
we already have you know this customer
population where we're getting the data
from so how can we add more um and it's
possible especially when it comes to
like more regulated environments because
now you don't have as much of an issue
with the regulations and the second is
you can op optimize the hyper parameters
for the client side so you know each um
of the clients will have their own model
as long as they have the same model
architecture you can optimize the hyper
parameters to try to get a better
performance um from the local model and
then hopefully from the overall Global
model and the third is just to test out
those different model aggregation
techniques so I have um a demo
and just for the sake of Simplicity with
the um mirroring screens I'm going to go
through the code that you can use to set
up a flower server and to set up the
different
clients so with flower you just need I'm
just going to make sure that you guys
can read this you read what's on the
screen okay so to get started with flow
it just takes one line of code to set up
the server um you import the package and
you just have to define a server address
so in this demo um which I will give the
code GitHub link for um when you run
this you bring up the server on Port 880
locally but otherwise um you can Define
you know like whatever server you
want the next thing you have to do is
Define each of your clients
so okay
so each of your clients needs to have um
some kind of model that it kind of can
use
so there are um we're using this mest
client which basically just used an M
the Mist model and we're defining like
the fit and the
evaluate um which will help us G gather
the performance metrics at the end um
and for this you just want to make sure
that your client knows where the server
address is and how to like you know how
to create that client so for the all
three of our clients we are going to
define the Mist client that is defined
above um and if you want you can use
this um base class or numy client to
make it a little easier to U make sure
that the client is configured and the
way that will you know make training
easier with Federated
learning um and just to show you the
model that's underlying it's just this
simple um nness model that isn't too bad
but you can put in your own model here
and kind of optimize the hyper
parameters if you want to be super
specific for each
client so that is um basically all you
need to get running and if you wanted to
run this you would just make sure that
you start up your server and then spin
up all of your clients so your server
will then wait to see if at least one
client has connected it'll then get the
run the training of the model on that
first client get the weights and then
kickoff training for all the other
clients that have connected to it and
give you the end performance
metrics
so overall federative learning um allows
you to have a more secure way to train
your model and because you're getting
the predict the predictions are running
locally on your device you get the
predictions in real time because you
don't have to wait for that lag between
the device to communicate with the
server and run the predictions on the
server and it also allows you to have
more divers Diversified training data
set because you get access access to um
more data due to the you know compliance
with
regulation so having used federative
learning and flower before there are a
few things that I would kind of put in
mind to consider when deciding how to
use Federated learning or if it's the
right thing to use for your project um
and that might make life easier when
working with it the first one is you're
constrained by your client's resour
sources so because the like because
Federated learning requires um the
device to have enough compute you want
to make sure that your model is able to
run on whatever compute that all of your
devices have because you can't just
scale up your server like you could with
classical machine learning and
distributed machine learning um so
ensuring that your you know model is
either tiny enough or that your devices
even have compute to train a model is
important
the second is that it requires fast
reliable networking meaning like if you
can't communicate between your devices
and the server then that um model weight
back and forth can't happen which means
that the server will never be able to
aggregate all of the model weights for
all of your clients so making sure that
you have designed a scenario where there
is um connectivity is important
and the third is that you won't be able
to run a typical data pre-processing
pipeline like you would traditional
machine learning so with traditional
machine learning you know you have all
of your data that's aggregated on the
server and you put it through this nice
preprocessing Pipeline and then you can
kick off training um but since you are
not actually moving copying or really
touching the data on the server um you
don't have that luxury of defining this
nice pre-processing pipeline to make
sure that all of your data is in a
format that the training pipeline
expects so typically this uh approach
works best with like ident identically
independently distri IID data um you can
use it with non IID data but you would
have to make sure that you've designed
the processing of the data so it doesn't
really depend on all of your data being
accumulated in one place um honestly
that part is the hardest part of
federative learning and it's something
to keep in mind just understanding what
your input data is and how much it
varies um can really help in the end in
terms of understanding why the metrics
turned out the way they
did so just to leave you with one last
quote um by Andrew n Federated learning
is the future of AI
development um so I hope that this talk
has kind of helped you understand a
little bit more about how federative
learning works and how flower works and
if you want to run the demo locally
you'll need Docker um or you can copy
over the Python scripts into your um IDE
but that just copy this tiny URL and my
contact is on my website as
well so thank you so much for the talk
and yeah I'm here for
[Applause]
questions than you very much um I have
two questions so first question is uh so
we have client uh contributor and the
server which is aggregate you Aggregates
data how does the pricing work Works
between iner prise pretty
regularly and uh the second question is
uh do you pass the weights around or
the okay um can you repeat your first
question so let's say you do the feder
between Enterprise how does the pricing
work because clients should pay the I
clients
P
res oh okay um so it sounds like the
first questioning is around how pricing
Works in Federated learning compared to
traditional ml yeah like areator P for
the prices
or how
yeah so I mean I can't give like exact
numbers it obviously varies for each
project but um from my project I know
that the computation is like or sorry
the pricing is a little bit lower
because you're not paying for the
compute to actually train the model your
server is merily just aggregating all of
the weights which takes like a lot less
resources um and mo since the most of
the training is happening on the device
um um which you don't pay for unless
you're in a scenario where you do um I
think the cost is like a little bit
lower for particularly like the training
part of the model um I'm trying to think
and then you also don't pay for storing
all of that data so your storage cost
should also be like minimal um I know
that my team set up you know a really
simple server and they just used S3 to
kind of coordinate the model weights
aggregation um and so that was really
minimal cost but it totally depends on
how you've designed your pipeline
definitely varies and what's your second
question um do you pass the weights or
the um you pass the
weights pass the upd exactly you pass
the updated weights after the training
and evaluation run Al for all the
mods how would you do with
explainability issues if you don't have
access to the data sets that on the
devices okay so the question is around
how do you deal with explainability
issues if you don't have access to the
data that's on the devices so um I'm
assuming you mean like explainability of
the final AI model in terms of how you
trained it yes I particularly because
want to one of the arguments for using
this is that your data is extremely
sensitive so I work in under a hippoc
constraint okay and let's just say our
compliance attorney is paranoid even by
hipper
standards so if I can't do at least some
level of explainability and refer it
back to the
data how do I deal with that yeah um so
I worked on a project where we were also
training on Healthcare data across
several hospitals so um I know that we
had to comply witha regulation and had
to submit a lot of documentation to the
FDA for the model um what we did was we
were able to kind of talk to the
hospitals and get like some permission
to at least do some data analysis on the
data itself we didn't copy or move the
data over but because of the nature of
that project and the Sens like the Sens
of like particularly patient data um we
did look at the memrs themselves so I
think for that case that's what I would
suggest is seeing if you could actually
like do analysis on the underlying data
on the server that it resides on so you
don't have to move it but you can also
still look at it yeah any other
questions yes um are there seems like
you're talking
about
can you um rephrase the
question sure
um are you talking about where is
restriction you have certain patients on
one server and certain patients on
another server or are you also talking
about situations where you have patients
with some data on one server and other
data other comp of data on a different
server and also my follow question is
like is there some restriction in terms
of just opening and merging these data
frame that you can't do as
well yeah um so the question was around
like if the like what the configuration
is in terms of how the data is
distributed is that across the servers
um as well
as what what situations require
Federated learnings okay sorry I'm just
trying to condense it um so in my case
we had like different hospitals have
their own server and they had all of
their patients data but to train one
Global model that you know for example
like was able to predict the onset of
breast cancer we wanted to train on
multiple hospitals data and each of
those hospitals require that their data
stayed on their own like Amazon S3
instance
and so in that case like it doesn't
matter whether you have like patients
split across servers it just depends on
what the regulation is in terms of
whether you're allowed to touch or move
the data from that server at all or not
um so that's kind of where it could
totally depends on the industry and the
like National laws like you know um and
so I don't know exactly like for all the
situations I just know that that was our
situation um and then did I answer your
well I also like are situations where
you have um data on the same client same
where some of the DAT is in one place
some of is in place different Columns
of I didn't have that situation but I
have heard of that situation and I think
um yes yes it
is I have a general question about fated
learning concept uh when you have many
devices of doing the learning and then
sending the way to a central don't you
have now a security problem with um the
different devices you don't control the
security you don't control the Integrity
of the mods running on these devices or
the Integrity of the data and I don't
know what kind of devices you're talking
about but they could be compromised and
you don't have any control over that
that's true um so one famous use case
for Federated learning is the like
Google keyboard like swie um and I think
Apple Siri and they use our like voice
reportings and our like text to train
their models in order to get that
functionality um so in that case they
have no control for example over your
cell phone and the security around it I
think that's where it calls for how much
that matters in terms of the quality of
the data for those uh products they
decided like okay we just want all the
data possible and we don't really care
for example like what the quality of
that data is like but it just just
depends
um thank you
yeah